we have an exciting exclusive
announcement about the upcoming film
weird the al yankovic story actress
quinta brunson will play oprah oh
okay here's a photo of her
alongside daniel radcliffe who's
starring as the man better known as
weird al brunson recently made what do
you think
she's got it right gail well i like i
like quinta and i like oprah so i'm
cheering yeah we're cheering him on
brunswick recently made headlines
because she was the first black woman to
receive three comedy emmy nominations in
the same year and they were all for the
breakout sitcom abbott elementary which
she created and she also stars in and
it's so good you said you're right i
started watching it we watched halfway
through we're halfway through the season
isn't it great it's so good it is so so
good uh weird the al yankovic story
chronicles the rise to stardom of one of
america's most beloved parody performers
it has set the stream on the roku
channel but no release date has yet been
set you make it sound like it's a
serious biopic i think that'd be making
fun of mine
it's gonna be a good i'm excited for it
i think it's gonna be great